so did anything interesting happen this
weekend
in the wake of the now infamous second
third trump tape in which the president
seemed to try to influence
the georgia secretary of state brad
raffensberger
and said specifically i just want to
find 11
780 votes people are wondering if this
is criminal conduct and if the president
is going to be prosecuted well putting
aside the issue of the criminality i'm
going to
try and do a video on that as soon as
possible some people are pretty sure
that this is criminal conduct including
potentially one of the members of the
georgia state election board who has
asked brad raffensburger to start a
criminal investigation brad
raffensberger has said that
he is not going to engage in an
investigation but he left open the
possibility
that the fulton county district attorney
could very well start an investigation
so stick around for that video it's
going to be coming out very very soon
and check out my other
eagle briefs where i talk about the
legal issues and i'll see you in court